let's get back to the phones at
617-830-4750
i want to talk to our caller
from the 202 area code who's calling
today from 202.
hi david this is rachel from the uh
maryland settler
suburbs of dcc love it and and rachel
you don't have us on speakerphone do you
i do not you're on a headset are you
unable to hear me
you know it's okay i think we can deal
with it
okay so my question to you is around
like the corporate liability shields
um it seems like that's mcconnell's like
red line
uh and he doesn't care about
anything else my question to you
is do you think this is something the
democrats might cave from
okay von i mean they've kind of some
have kind of postured around
um not you know that being a non-starter
but i mean basically the language that
was submitted
came from you know cuomo's liability
shield that he
you know uh put in in new york to use in
new york
so rachel let me explain to people first
what you're talking about so people know
so
the idea here is donald trump floated
this starting a couple of months ago the
idea is
a liability shield for businesses who
reopen
where they would not be subject to a
lawsuit
or or criminal or civil proceedings of
any kind
if people catch coronavirus at their
place of business it could be employees
and it could be customers the idea being
if a business
thinks wait a second if my employees get
sick or customers get sick i could get
sued
they'd be less likely to open so donald
trump side as a way to
really encourage businesses to open
you know i i i would have my answer
two weeks ago rachel might have been
more definitive at this point i think
everything is on the table
i think uh given what's going on and
given how far apart the negotiations
seem to be
democrats more than republicans seem
extremely eager to get
money to people and get money in
people's hands that they might be
willing to concede
i i would not it's a question mark for
me i wouldn't put anything past anyone
at this
point particularly when you've got an
election in three months and so a lot of
the players who are up for re-election
in the senate
are going to be thinking about what
they're willing to do versus what
they're willing to give up
in order to facilitate getting
re-elected as well
so it's a crap shoot right now anything
could happen
yeah i mean i'm i'm just very concerned
that it could lead to
a potential fight because once you have
people who are absolved of liability
then their interest in trying to do
everything they can to maintain worker
and consumer safety
becomes a little less i mean we saw what
happened in the nursing homes in new
york
so i'm just that that's really what you
know it's concerning to me is that could
it lead to a further spike
well listen the answer is yes and of
course
we may be on the way to a further uh
spike anyway
and we were supposed to have a break
between wave one and two
it's not clear that's going to happen so
yeah all these factors are going to add
it's it's looking like it's going to be
a very difficult fall in the united
states
absolutely great well thanks david
thanks rachel appreciate the phone call